Kouga race is a 654 foot car transport
ship that at the time in late July was
doing a trip from Japan to the US
carrying about 4,000 Mazdas on board had
a crew of 23 and it flipped over on its
side
and everybody on board went slamming
down to one side one guy snapped his leg
and they all climbed up to the high side
of the ship and 24 hours later were
taken off via helicopter by the US Coast
Guard every transport ship carries
ballast water to keep it stable and in
the case of the Cougar race the crew
accidentally pumped all the ballast
water out of one side of the ship so
suddenly the ship became completely
unstable and when it rolled on the swell
it had nothing to keep its right side
down so it just flipped over which is
where the crew from Titan salvage found
it when they boarded via helicopter when
big ships run into trouble there is a
limited number of people who have the
expertise to try to save the ship and so
the insurance companies that that
represent the ship owners have basically
a short list of people that they call
around the world and Titan Salvage is
one of these rare companies there is a
guy who can pilot any sized ship in the
world there's a guy who's a welder can
weld anything there's a big engine
mechanic the deep-sea divers and then
there's a computer modeling guy whose
job it is to build a 3d model of the
ship on the fly and help the team figure
out how to fix the ship before they
actually implement the plan and what
these guys do is they work in a somewhat
obscure program called general
hydrostatics
that allows them to build a model of the
ship and then move water move cargo move
all the elements that are on a ship
around to try to figure out what is
going to be needed to either right the
ship or to pull the ship off ground if
it's if it's grounded the way these guys
work is that if they don't succeed in
saving the ship they don't get paid but
if they do succeed they make a
percentage of the ship and its cargo so
on a you know
on the Kouga race for instance which was
the cargo was worth 103 million
approximately and the ship was worth
more than 100 million the guys made
north of 10 million dollars in the last
three years three guys have died on the
job which you know averages out to a guy
a year so it's very risky Marty Johnson
was one of the country's most respected
and accomplished naval architects
unfortunately on on their first day on
the ship as they were as they were
trying to get off the ship marty was
carrying a backpack that had about 30 or
40 pounds worth of gear in it and they
were climbing down these crazy rope
ladders and the decks you have to
remember were sixty degrees so it's
basically like climbing down a steep
rock face except that it's all steel and
completely slick so one slip and you're
gone and that's what happened to Marty
he slipped and he wasn't clipped into a
rope and he fell 80 feet and hit his
head on a big metal bollard and and that
was basically it
you